[MUSIC PLAYING]
-The Radcliffe Institute
is Harvard's institute
for advanced study.
Our mission is to
foster cutting-edge work
across the disciplines--
the arts, the humanities,
the sciences, and
the social sciences.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE AND MUSIC PLAYING]
-I'm an associate professor in
chemical engineering at MIT.
My research is focused on
engineering of microbes
for chemical production.
A really nice benefit
of being here at Harvard
is having the time
and the proximity
to really have interactions
with other people
doing research here
on Harvard's campus.
Radcliffe was really an
interesting environment
for me as well, in
terms of thinking
about how the work
that we do in my lab
has an impact on the
rest of the world.
I actually was involved in
two federal government reports
during my time at Radcliffe.
And the Radcliffe
fellowship year
really gave me the opportunity
to dedicate real time to those.
I think, when I look
back at the year
that I've spent at
Radcliffe, I will
remember being very productive.
I had more papers that were
submitted for publication
than I've ever had at
any point in my career.
-Kristala Prather.
-And I'll remember the
people and the exposure
to all these other different
areas of work, many of which
have such a profound
impact on my life
just as a citizen of
the world, as well
as a citizen of this country.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
-I am a junior in
Leverett House,
and I'm studying
comparative literature,
with a secondary in government.
Being part of the Radcliffe
Research Partnership, I think,
has made me connected to
a larger academic world
beyond the world of
college and classes.
This year, I'm working
with Professor Ziblatt,
who's a government
professor at Harvard.
-I'm writing a book this year on
the rise of democracy in Europe
historically.
-So like who the people are.
-I've spent the last
several years working
on Germany and Britain
over a 100-year period,
but I needed help with
the last part of the book.
I'm trying to extend the lessons
of this particular historical
experience into other countries.
-And so the idea that
even though there
were these new parties there,
the informal power structure of
[INAUDIBLE] was maintained.
-I speak French and
I speak Spanish,
so I was able to read text
that he wasn't able to read.
So I would share with
him what I'd learned,
and he would see how that
connected to the research
that he'd done in the
meantime, and how it connected
more generally to his argument.
-So in a way, that was
a kind of a reversal
of the traditional role
of professor and student.
And she was actually
teaching me.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
-I think the reason
for the DNA symposium
was just the
incredible development
in the last several years, the
last decade, of DNA science,
of synthetic biology, of
really exploding information
about our ancestry
and our origins that
are revealed by DNA analysis.
And we thought, wow,
what an exciting moment
to bring it all together.
-This technology
is new, very new.
And so in addition
to the science, today
we'll be discussing the ethical
aspects of this new world.
-We had anthropologists.
We had evolutionary biologists.
We had chemists.
We had criminal justice.
We had an ethicist.
-They brought together
different areas of research
that I am interested
in, but might not have
talked to in the same room.
-Today's been incredible.
It's a great opportunity
to hear about research
from around the world in a
completely interdisciplinary
way.
So you get totally outside of
your specific little bubble
that you study.
-But I also think bringing it
to the public is absolutely key.
This stuff has enormous
ethical implications.
It has enormous implications
for human health.
It has big implications
for how we see ourselves.
And that can only be addressed
in an interdisciplinary setting
like Radcliffe.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
-We have the world's
leading collection
of materials around
women's rights movements,
from the first stirrings of
such movements in the 1830s
and 1840s, through what we
call second wave feminism,
and on into today.
Bill Baird was a
really important player
in the reproductive rights
pieces of those movements.
The Bill Baird collection
is the largest collection
a library has ever acquired.
700 plus boxes came out
of Mr. Baird's basement.
One of the things that was
carted out of his basement
was a carton of
badly burned books.
The first act of domestic
terrorism against an abortion
provider was leveled
against Baird.
His offices were firebombed.
It's going to be
important, in 100 years,
literally to demonstrate
the heat of this argument.
I think one of the truly
remarkable things about Baird
is that he treated his
opponents in the Right to Life
movement with enough seriousness
to collect their materials.
Having the pro-life materials,
the anti-choice materials
in the Baird collection, I think
is really of inestimable value.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
-At Radcliffe, we're
fortunate enough
to have built a new gallery,
the Johnson Kulukundis Family
Gallery.
And for the
inaugural exhibition,
we were really looking for a
work that would showcase what
the gallery was capable of.
teamLab is an artistic
collective in Japan
that counts over 400 members.
And it consists of engineers,
computer scientists, artists,
architects, designers,
people involved
in all kinds of
different specialties.
[CHATTERING]
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
-Ours is a vision in
which art is integrated
with other forms of study,
engages our senses afresh,
and challenges us to
assemble and to present
meaning in new ways.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
-The Radcliffe
Institute is vibrant.
It's intellectually
exciting, and it is creative.
-If it was just all content,
all knowledge, all search.
-I was firing on
all my cylinders,
and this was an
absolutely dreamy place
to be working on the project.
-A rewarding experience you
just don't get in the classroom.
You don't get in your
extracurriculars either.
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
-The Radcliffe Institute is a
new star in the Harvard galaxy.
And it's going to become
brighter and brighter
as time goes on.
[MUSIC PLAYING]